This is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich and our topic today on Radiolab.
Is Zoos the saddest places on the planet?
What do I have to do? No, they're not the satisfaction. You know, I'm right.
The point look,
despite everything we've said up to now about the true wildness of a zoo animal,
the fact remains,
looking into the eyes of we live animal can be an extraordinarily transformative
experience, and don't ask me, ask Alan Rabinowitz. Okay.
I am Alan Rabinowitz. She's going to be our last stop on the show.
I'm the head of a program that seeks to explore the earth's last great wild
areas and try to protect them.
Alan Rabinowitz is around Noun,
animal conservation as he set up wildlife preserves all over the world and jazz
like you. He's not particularly thrilled by zoos,
although without a zoo, and I'm thinking of the Bronx Zoo in particular,
he wouldn't be who he used today because when Allen was very young, very young,
he had a terrible stutter. Oh, I couldn't talk.
My Body would spasm you. So if you wanted to say coming,
mom,
is he Cummings a hard contact coming is the tongue against the upper palate so
you couldn't get the word out.
I didn't speak a fluent sentence to another human being until I went to this.
Finally, this clinic, when I was a senior in college, a senior in college,
I never went on a date. I never kissed a girl other than my mom.
Anybody connect to anybody? I had no friends.
That's how I had none.
I had little animals that I would take into the closet with me and I would talk
to them fluently and that's how it was for Alan for much of his childhood.
The only time he says he could free his tongue to talk was in the dark with his
pets, green turtles,
hamsters and shareables and and chameleons, which would all die.
I would talk the way we're talking.
I could talk fluently to the animals and his father one time overheard him
talking to the dark. I thought, well, maybe we should take this boy to the zoo,
to the Bronx zoo, to the Bronx. He used to bring me to the old great cat house.
Horrendous. You remember the great gray cat, classic,
old concrete floors, but you'd go in,
I mean talk about an experience you've walk in and here growler Rari.
I mean it sounded incredible. Raw power
and he loved being there.
He just loved all those noises of like 20 cats all together,
vocalizing at the same time.
Maybe it was the sound which appealed to me as a kid that couldn't speak.
And once again in front of the Katz was with, he was alone. You could talk.
Yes, my father.
It's funny cause he knew I talked to the animals so he would stand back.
He knew if he came too close I'd stopped because I would stutter cause he was
there. But if he wasn't, you could talk more fluently. I can talk fluently.
And there was one, one old Jaguar
and I remember as a kid I would stand there and I would watch that.
I'd watched this magnificent, huge, strong beast.
This massive, strong animal had blank eyes.
It just looked blank and it was pacing back and forth and back and forth.
I felt this animals like me cause I felt strong. I felt good,
I felt powerful inside,
but yet I was trapped inside this cage of my buddy and that's what Alan
Remembers. Turning to that cat as a kind of fellow exile
and whispering a promise that I would try to find a place for us.
I remember that.
I remember saying once I'll find a place for us,
and they didn't mean that particular, I don't know what I mean.
I can't really look back and know exactly what I meant,
but I felt no matter what I would find a place for us.
Okay.
And that problem, I would find a place for us.
You kept that promise in his head for for two decades he went on and visit a
speech therapist.
He learned how to use his mouth and tongue to get past his stutter,
not completely,
but enough to finish college and then go on to graduate school and Study
Wildlife Ecology and it was at his graduation party from graduate school.
We got the offer that would change his life that my going away party,
my major professor asked me if I wanted to go to Belize and do and study
Jaguars, not just study them,
count them in an objective survey of how many Jaguars are really in the country
and ask how do you count Jaguars and that's when the professor said, well,
you got to catch him. Catch a Jaguar. How do I know? I have no idea.
It's like saying, go catch a dragon.
Everybody knew the Jaguars are still the almost Ghostlight cats in a forest.
Nobody had ever kept your Jaguars in the range fires.
That was exactly what the professor was proposing.
Go to a little country in Central America.
Please go deep into it's jungle collar,
as many jaguars as you can so that we can track them and learn about them.
Weeks past,
picture Allan on the edge of the jungle in Belize with absolutely no idea what
to do next. We opened the map of beliefs.
It had one dirt road down the entire country.
Allan figures the only way he's going to catch a Jag.
What do I do this just to talk to people who hunt? Jaguars. Oh, they're there.
They're a,
he calls the Mayans and they live in the farm forest and I went to to,
to the hunters and they told me run them with dogs and one hunter still had
Jaguar dogs and I'll tell you of everything I've ever done in my life,
I still ranked that as the absolute hardest because when these dogs get on a
Jaguar scent, it's a blood [inaudible].
You're running full speed through the jungle.
The Mayans are in front of us running and chopping at the same time.
And I knew in my mind that that would poison the snakes,
but you can't think about it. Good.
You don't have time to look what you're running or get beat.
And one time dashing behind dogs and machete waving hunters,
disaster struck. He would just about the actually triaging.
One of the crew got beat by a poisonous snake and he died.
So everybody quit. Nobody had worked for me. They all thought I was Jenks.
So then I had to figure out how to capture Jaguars by myself.
Nobody works with me. Finally,
one Mayan Indian came to work for me and we ended up building traps and I would
put live pigs because they didn't want dead meat. They would want live meat,
which they could kill themselves.
So I put live pigs in the back of these traps and have to go feed the pigs every
single day. The first trap I built, I built it out of two by fours.
I caught a Jaguar.
The Jaguar chewed its way through the two by four door and busted its way out of
the two by four slow.
I mean they are powerful animals and then I built ion rebar.
Even then I made a mistake.
One Jaguar got so mad it bit the iron rebar and polled at the eye and rebar and
snapped its canines.
It snapped its own canines trying to bust the iron rebar.
Okay.
I mean its roots were hanging out and I put it down.
I tried to do preventive dentistry,
I had to cut the roots and it was lying there dying and I just felt so bad.
Okay.
I carried the Jaguar back to my cabin.
I lay next to it and it died on the floor next to me. I just lost it.
I lost it. But one good thing came out of this experience.
He learned to build a better trap. And so cat by cat,
by Cat Allen was able, and he was the first to do this.
He was able to count the Jaguars in that forest and there were thousands of
them, but he had the sense, and again this was,
he was first that they were in real danger because around them people were
cutting down their forest. Then if the forest went, the Jaguars go to.
So that's when he began, uh, the campaign,
which eventually led him to the prime minister.
I was given a chance and not only did the,
did the prime minister agree to meet me, but he,
he invited me to address him in the whole cabinet, but only 15 minutes.
Now remember,
this is a guy who for two whole decades could barely speak his stutter,
which is now less of a problem, was still there.
And now he's being asked to address a prime minister and a cabinet in a high
pressure. Make it a break. At 15 minutes or last situation,
I knew I couldn't stutter. I mean I only had 15 minutes. I said, look,
you will lose nothing by this. If you don't protect it,
guaranteed it's going to be gone because the citrus people want it for both
timber and citrus. Make it a forest reserve and make it tentative.
Make it a five year agreement. If I can prove to you,
I can bring in far bringing in outside money in five years,
what do you have to lose? And if it works,
you've got a Jaguar preserve. You have the world's first Jaguar preserve.
Now his pitch was supposed to last 15 minutes up to the time he was allotted,
but he went way over.
I ended up staying in there an hour and a half and the vote was a tie in the
cabinet.
The prime minister himself broke the tie in Alan's favorite and by the anti
grid. The prime minister voted in my favor. That made it.
It got great press as the world's first Jaguar preserve. To this day,
it's the world's only area designated specifically as a Jaguar prison.
And by the way, the whole time with the prime minister and all that whole time,
he never stuttered
[inaudible]
so Alan decided his work was more or less done.
He could go home now to New York and just before he left,
he decided to go for one last walk in the jungle. The last visit,
he wasn't looking for Jaguars, he wasn't expecting to see one,
this was his goodbye.
But when he was looking down at the ground as you walked along,
suddenly he thought, well, hello,
because they're on the ground right in front of him,
was a fresh print of a Jaguar,
a big one, bigger than any I had seen in that area.
And that just got my blood, the blood going.
So I started following it. You almost never,
never see a Jaguar when you follow its tracks because it knows you're there.
I mean, I was hoping against hope and maybe I'd see the Jaguar,
but actually I didn't think I would because they always knew I was coming and
they'd always go away. And then it started getting dye started getting laid,
and I didn't want to be in the jungle at night and I'd have a flashlight or
anything.
So that's when I turned around there was the Jaguar about 15 feet away behind
you. It was behind me, been behind me, probably quite a ways.
So it knew that you were tracking it and it decided to find out who you were.
It circled around and it probably cut off into the forest.
Watch me as I passed,
then got back on the trail and just stayed back a good ways.
And it was pretty clear this cat had been creeping closer and closer to where by
the time I turned around and shortened the distance between us, really small.
I mean that was, so, he was in leaping distance.
I couldn't have gotten away from it. And I knew that.
So I did what I thought was the right thing,
which is make myself small, make myself subdominant,
just crouched down and then a Jaguar did something which I didn't expect it to
do. It sat down.
That was strange to me
and then I got scared and I stood up and I stepped back because I felt the
distance was too close now that that it didn't like and all this time,
I mean I'm totally aware, I have no place to go
and with no place to go, nowhere to run.
Alan just stood there frozen in place and the Jaguar Rosen hit too.
Just stood absolutely silent.
Then it just turned, started walking off into the general
and before it disappeared into the rush,
it turned back to look at me
[inaudible].
Then I really looked at it in the eyes and they were wild eyes.
There was fire in the Jaguar's eyes.
The last thing I remember very clearly is looking into to its size and thinking
of seeing the Jaguar in the Bronx Zoo as a child,
but seeing the wildness in this animal's eyes.
It didn't look anything like that cat and the cage.
It showed strength and freedom and then we had just protected this incredible
area which now would be its home and I remember telling the cat at one point
that I'd find a place for us.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
Dr Alan Rabinowitz is the director for science and exploration at the wildlife
conservation society and if you want to be more about his Jaguar Adventures and
beliefs, the book is called Jaguar,
one man's struggle to establish the world's first Jaguar preserve.
We should wrap up for more information on anything that you heard today.
Check our website, radiolab.org got a podcast we do.
You can sign up for it there or at iTunes and send us an email.
Let us know what you think. Radio lab at W N Y C dot.
Org is the address on Radiolab is one word. It is. I'm Jetta. Boom. Ron.
I'm Robert Krulwich and we'll see you at the zoo. We'll see what the zoo,
at least some of us
first message. Radiolab is produced by Jad Abumrad, Ellen Holen,
senior producer, Lulu Miller, assistant producer,
production executive Dean Capello. Production support base,
their repeller Greeny, Brett buyer, Scott Goldberg, Alaska Keville,
Sam Libby de Davian, Mitra Ryan Scammell, and Jacob Weinberg.
Also very special thanks to Tamar Lewin and Amy Bush's class at North Star
Academy for them musical contributions.